hey i'm back with another video today we're
going to talk about statins okay it is very very
essential for you to understand this information
now statins work by blocking a certain enzyme
that blocks your production of cholesterol your
liver cells make a good amount of cholesterol
in your body so the cholesterol in your body is
not just coming from the diet it's coming from
your own cells and it has some very important
purposes number one it's a precursor for making
bile salts which is involved in digesting fats
absorbing fat cypo vitamins like vitamin a
e d k omega 3 fatty acids etc etc cholesterol
is also necessary in making bile salts
so if you don't have enough bile salts your risks
for gall stones go up your risk for pancreatitis
increases because if you have bile sludge
that's going to block the pancreatic ducts
and causing a back up into the pancreas so there's
so many side effects of statin but the big one
is myopathy now that's a gentle term for muscle
disease because statins have a direct effect
on the muscle they can create necrosis of
the muscle which basically kills the muscle
they can cause muscle cell apoptosis which is
another term for the muscle cells dying you can
get all sorts of inflammatory muscle
problems weakness of the muscle pain
in the muscle stiffness in the muscle and even
an autoimmune condition of the muscle as well
another side effect is high levels of something
called creatinine kinase which indicates muscle
wasting and that can increase by 10x now there's
also the topic of why your cholesterol is high
in the first place and let's say it even goes up
is there any problem with having high cholesterol
i'm going to leave that for another video but in
this video i want to talk to the person who's on
statins and what you can do to reduce the symptoms
of myopathy now there's something else that
a statin will deplete and that is something
called coq10 it's an enzyme involved in giving
your muscles energy and you may have seen it
at the healthy store mainly for heart problems
if you're deficient in coq10 you get muscle
wasting muscle weakness low back pain
again a problem in the muscle um heart failure and
the list goes on and on and on so the more statin
you take the more deficient in coq10 you're going
to be and it just happens that if you take coq10
you can greatly diminish the symptoms of myopathy
when someone's on a statin drug so this video is
mainly about those people that are taking statins
that apparently for some reason have to take it
they're getting side effects and they might not
know how simple it is to relieve the complications
from this medication so start taking coenzyme q10
and if i were you i would double or triple the
dosage if you're taking the statin and as you're
coping with statins i would highly recommend you
also learn more about cholesterol how to keep it
in check and what diet you need to be on if you're
new to my channel i put the links down right there
check it out before you go if you have a question
about a product or you're new to keto and you
want to know how to begin keto or you're on keto
and you need a debug because it's not going
as smooth i have a keto consultant standing
by to help you this is just for the people in
the u.s hopefully in the future we'll be able
to answer everyone's call but i put the number
down below so you can call and get some help